community we often use that word to
describe who we are and what connects
all of us involved in the different
elements that bring a film from an idea
in the writers of mind to its premiere
on the big screen each person each craft
each discipline is essential to that
process deep down we know that we always
have and in the end this truly
collaborative community comes together
on a night like this
to celebrate this past year and to look
forward to the next it is a true honor
for me to present this next award live
on camera not during the commercial
break Thank You Academy here are the
nominees for achievement in
cinematography whoo Casa
the favorite Robby Ryan never look away
Caleb Deschanel Roma Alfonso Cuaron a
star is born
Matthew Liberty and the Oscar goes to
Alfonso cuarón
[Applause]
alfonso cuarón is the fourth person to
receive four nominations in four
different award categories for the same
film this is his third Oscar and tenth
nomination
[Applause]
thank you so much this is an amazing
honor thank you Academy to create a
single frame of film as you will now
requires the work of a lot of people a
very hard work so I want to thank
yelitza Parisien medina de vida for
anybody else the amazing cast and crew
Gabriella Rodriguez Nicolas alias
producers participant and Netflix
technique Technicolor Inari a the if the
mem if this film was created by the
memory my own memories
the film was crafted through the
memories of what these great masters in
the mythography have given to us is well
known that in Billy Wilder's
office there was a sign that said what
would you which have done and for me was
what would she wear she volu basket
would have done so this is for you to
see boom and thank you very much Mexico
City my family and among it and for
Naboo a Alma love you guys thank you